hello and welcome back to the cheeky
sign jus so in today's video we're going
to look at the pros and cons of
genome-wide Association studies so
before I jump straight in and tell you
about the pros and cons I'll first
introduce you to what are genome-wide
Association studies and then after
looking at the pros and cons we'll look
at what polygenic risk scores are and
how genome-wide Association studies are
used to look at putting at risk scores
so firstly what are genome-wide
Association studies so genome-wide
Association studies are used to identify
gene loci associated with a trait or
phenotype of interest so the idea is
that you look across the entire genome
and try to identify single nucleotide
polymorphisms as you can see here with T
a and G and whether or not the T the a
witha G is associated with a phenotype
of interest so let's say people who had
a T instead of an a were also had the
phenotype of being really tall and so
that could be a low save associated with
the traits of being tool that make sense
and so if you do this across the entire
genome you'll find that certain leucite
are more likely to be associated with
that phenotype than others and ones that
surpass the threshold are of interest
because it suggests that that is a low
site why there was a correlation between
having that genetic variant and the
traits so in previous videos I've
already given examples of where
genome-wide Association studies have
been done for example I gave an example
of where it's been done with chronotype
and also with obesity but this paper
here is a recent paper that's forces on
a genome-wide Association study with
Lisa associated with same-sex sexual
behavior and so my point is is that they
are happening all the time and can be
done with many different phenotypes but
why do them what are the benefits of
genome-wide Association studies so
firstly the beauty of genome-wide
Association studies are that they are
hypotheses free
you don't need to know anything
beforehand and so starting from nothing
you can identify a site that have genes
that are likely associated with the
phenotype that you're studying and then
these genes can be further characterized
and understood to understand what causes
the phenotype of interest
wow that was a long-winded explanation
but genome-wide Association studies may
also have therapeutic potential as we'll
see later when we look at polygenic
Briscoes and lastly the data for
genome-wide Association studies requires
sequencing data which is becoming ever
more prevalent and so is technically
quite easy to get now or at least easier
than it was previously
and these datasets can be even more
informative when they're combined with
other studies as well and actually
combining genome-wide Association
studies with other studies helps they
become some of the limitations that I've
seen with genome-wide Association
studies so one experiment that I mean is
single-cell RNA sequencing data because
with that information you can see which
genes are being expressed in a cell and
which shells from assassin tissue and so
if you can see the same subset of genes
being expressed as the same subset of
genes identified from a genome-wide
Association study you have a fuller
understanding and better confidence that
the genes that you're looking at are
possibly associated with the phenotype
that you're studying it would make more
sense probably if you had an example but
bear with me for now but there are
downsides to genome-wide Association
studies the first thing the keywords
Association Association of valais site
with the traits doesn't necessarily mean
causation and so the genes that are
being identified may have new world
value in terms of understanding the
cause of a phenotype so the next
limitation with genome-wide Association
studies is the missing heritability and
so what I mean by this is that if you
took all the low-side that surpassed the
thresholds of being associated with that
phenotype and you added them all
together the total sum of all those
those I in terms of the likelihood of
you getting that phenotype condition
that sees whatever you're looking at is
only around like two to three percent
maximum for most of these genome-wide
Association studies so what about you
know that the other 97% where is this
missing heritability and so part of this
issue comes from the fact that the low
site with like a strong link with the
phenotype I'm being identified and that
comes down to a kind of a flaw we're not
really a floor-by-floor of the
genome-wide Association studies that you
have your population of different whole
genome sequences that you're looking at
and you're trying to find lo site in all
of them all of the people with the
condition that have that trains that
have you know what I mean and the
problem is is if you're looking for
common variants you're going to miss the
rare variants that let's say one or two
people who have the condition also have
that variance and it seems possible that
these rare variants are the ones that
have a greater effect size as you can
see in the graph here but there is still
hope that these rare variants can be
identified given that now we have the
tools to easily from whole genome
sequencing and with this knowledge that
we could be missing them we're more
likely to look for the reference so
another limitation with genome-wide
Association studies is that it often
identifies loose I where you have a
genetic variant but not a gene why are
it's the genes that were more interested
in because then we can understand the
function of the gene where the genes
expressed I understand how that links it
to the phenotype and so certain reasons
could be that the low size and a
non-coding region in which case it could
be affecting the expression also not
just one gene but multiple genes that
altogether could be influenced in the
phenotype um there's also a linkage
disequilibrium whereby there might be
more than one gene
in that same region and/or there's so is
more to do the fact that there could be
multiple variants within a certain low
sign is determining which of those
variants is responsible and then lastly
is looking at which tissues important in
terms of the gene so as I said there
might be a gene that you've identified
but in might only be expressed and
Sasson tissues and so to get answers to
these different points you need to
combine genome-wide Association studies
with other experiments such as the RNA
sequencing data that I spoke about
earlier and another important issue that
is now being better addressed is the
lack of diversity in the studies at the
moment so a lot of the genome-wide
Association studies have used sequencing
data from mainly European populations
and say by including this including more
ethnicities into these studies could
also explain why there seems to be a
lack of heritability in the results and
so it would be valuable to include them
and so if some of these limitations can
be addressed there's great excitement
for genome-wide Association studies for
being used to generate polygenic riscos
whereby they can take your genetic
information and look at which less
variants you've got and therefore your
risk or likelihood of getting a certain
disease or phenotype and so this could
be the likelihood that you could get a
certain type of cancer and this
predictive information kids enable
better identification and early
identification of certain diseases which
will leads a better time available for
treatment and so by taking body mass
index as an example the greater your
polygenic risk or the greater the
prediction of your BMI is and so if you
did this across a population you would
see a bell curve for the distribution or
Fresco's and so the risk score could
have some
kind of predictive value for assessing
people who are high risk of having a
high BMI and getting obesity and
therefore could be targeted through
effective treatment but that's the key
thing that I need to emphasize it's
about whether or not a risk score can be
actionable and so this was actually
already done in a recent paper whereby
they used a genome-wide polygenic risk
score to quantify the inherited
susceptibility to obesity and they did
this to see if they could identify
adults at risk of severe obesity and the
idea is that if you can then
you can try and help to prevent that
from happening but the other key thing
is that these polygenic risk scores have
to be independent of other information
that you can already get so if you were
going to help somebody and that person
was already obese and getting a probably
done at risk score that tells you that
they're going to be obese is already
very much help then is it because it's
already gonna be obvious so it's all
about whether or not play gentle risk
scores are going to be actionable and
can be independent of other sources of
information that we can already attained
so I hope this video has given you a
good introduction to what genome-wide
Association studies are and their
benefits and the current limitations
with them but also what we can to you
with them so thanks for listening